[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich darf heute endlich
die zwei gewinner auslosen und farbe
alle hier drin sagt mir die kommentare
durchgelesen ich danke euch für die
komplimente ich danke euch für die
vorschläge habe ich mir alles notiert
wird alles gemacht und jetzt zum ersten
mal aktiv und zg schreibt mir eine
nachricht über youtube und ok ich hab
jetzt einmal kurz telefoniert aber das
windspiel die auslosungen die stand
gesetzt und die zwei gewinner die ich
gerade genannt hat die menschlich bitte
bei mir dann über die youtube
nachrichtenfunktion und dann können wir
alles weitere dann klären ich danke
einzelnes mitmachen und das gibt auf
jeden fall öfter auf meinem kanal und
angestellte zunächst einmal auf die ski